so many chances I think it's very
important to unbalance your opponent
when you play with the right pieces
definitely you have to win and we just
see what's going on on the board
and so far it's a repeat the Berlin
defense exactly what we saw earlier the
players are going copycat style wow what
is Magnus got up his sleeve so he could
just gonna play a 100 move Game beat
Wesley on the clock so far okay first
deviate deviation from that point the
white Bishop comes out to G5
painting black tonight this is rare
normally uh the white Bishop doesn't
really want to necessarily give itself
up for a black knight but Magnus forcing
Wesley to think it's only move seven and
the players have only used a few seconds
up to this point we can see Wesley is
surprised I was gonna say I was just
looking at the database and I'm like
says there are no no there has to be
some games there are some games not many
just one
line from Magnus absolutely
well it's a provocation Bishop G5 Bishop
H4 or that's how I'm taking it but let's
go play G5 and then we'll see but of
course Wesley is more solid than that
yeah and I must admit I'm surprised to
see Magnus try and strike in the center
uh he's pushed the white deep horn for a
second time in this game losing a bit of
time there and now big moment which way
does Wesley Castle he castles Queen side
I think that's a great move and it shows
Wesley Is Not Afraid at all black has
everything covered and uh yeah black is
actually ahead of development
potentially white is the one with a lot
of ground to cover in the middle of the
board and you mentioned the provocations
unit the advance has begun Wesley
stepping forward pushing pawns kicking
the black uh the white Bishop away from
the PIN
don't understand what Magnus is doing
here what his plan is well he's
attacking one in the center on E5 what
can Wesley do Knight D7
yeah hold the fort step back brace for
impact
then Knight C4 so
but I mean can't you go your night I was
going to say H5 as well is this a bone
sacrifice Knight H5 good move
yeah maybe a pawn sacrifice but a lot of
activity around the white king
looks like one-way traffic in terms of
who's playing for the initiative right
now
I was shaking his head yeah I would be
shaking my head too I've got to admit I
just don't think that this is the type
of position that can be easy to play in
an Armageddon let alone creating winning
chances for what it looks like Black's
having all the fun and it's far quicker
uh far easier uh speedier to attack than
it is to defend and is black actually
threatening to capture that pawn in the
middle of the board so I'm going to take
Bishop to xifa
just might as well suffer for something
right Judith yeah and I hope for the
best
perfectly but you're gonna suffer quite
a bit because after all the exchanges
there is night
in F3
but then
yeah so Magnus wasn't attracted by that
and instead reinforces the center well
he has a queen A4 in the pipeline
but his position doesn't look
all that
if I'm being honest
yeah an easy moves for for Wesley so he
just trades in the center opening things
up for his his Bishops isn't this a pawn
by the way if she takes the E4 Bishop
takes G3 and Rook D4
yeah
it looks like it's falling apart for
white
so what has Magnus got up his sleeve he
was the one who chose this opening
variation he did not surprise Wesley in
the end clock time still looking healthy
for Wesley over five minutes Magnus just
under the eight minute mark
time to actually come up with the queen
to A4
counter-attack Ivanka you want to go
after this loose A7 Pawn go for the
black king at least maybe gain a Tempo
and the process looks logical but some
calculation needs to be done there
Magnus burning the clock
yeah I do like uh this comment which
says no I keep the faith get brace
yourself for a brilliant move from
Magnus
he needs one he does need one I mean his
position looks like he's losing control
yeah and uh long think now over one
minute in an Armageddon game this is
potentially crucial what does he do now
he does simply capture and your question
now Judah is going to be answered can
black simply grab a pawn
take this bishop take this Pawn on D4
there's a pin this Knight is pinned so
the default Pawn is not truly protected
maybe he's just gonna gamble there just
move his queen and I hope for the best
I don't see it I think he can be greedy
here Wesley
well let's see if he's going to be
greedy yeah other options maybe include
bringing the bishop to B4 creating a
double pin
on this Diagon of this diagonal if you
want to be fancy but
he does go for that idea there we go
I mean you still have Knight takes
Bishop on your pocket and then the plan
of actually opening up the H line
yeah did you see Wesley looked up at the
screen where he could see what move
number it is he's already thinking about
getting to move 40 getting that a one
second increment but it's only moved 15.
miles away from that
he has he has a lot of moves to make
okay the query is a sacrifice Bishop F3
exchange is gone
wow but if you're in a in a situation
where a draw is equal to a win are you
gonna gamble with those type of moves
Queen A4 that Magnus has just played
yeah yeah he is gambling well exactly
but grabbing the material well where's
Leah you know he's a cool customer he
says yes absolutely so he's going to
take that rook and is Magnus going to
meet a capture of his Rook by taking
this black A7 Pawn
yeah but it is a wreck a true gamble
yeah I don't know if you have any check
mating attacks there
just have to hope for the best but it
feels like if you don't play that you're
just material down for free
he has to take this
yeah and the idea is to bring the white
knight forward to take away the black
King's Escape square but wow nice move
from Wesley there were some tactics
there the black queen was threatening to
go back to A5
oh G4 but
or takes first he trades but now there's
no background checkmate at least for
white the white King has some breathing
space so the White Knight can jump 95 on
G4 maybe
twins that's an opportunity
big threat Knight E5 takes away the
black King's Escape Square Queen A8 will
be a Checkmate Wesley needs something
now well can you not play F3 oh sorry F6
yeah classy control that white knight
exactly then I go E5
E6 another chapter
oh nothing gets past you uh whoa I think
Knight G3 I'm not sure it was good this
was a great gamble Suddenly at least
there's attacking chances and he's
forced Wesley to think three and a half
minutes for Wesley so he's not coming
back only one second increment after
move 40.
whites got a decision to make now no
Queen trade surely maybe you can give a
check to the black kid I can't come back
to A4 right
there we go he's gonna play that
Queen back somewhere
and the black king is out in the open
Magnus is back in business
at least it's double-edged now it's
extremely complicated he's got a knight
and a pawn for The Rook
and three minute time advantage and uh
could Wesley try to play it safe and to
actually step back with the King to C8
and say you know what I'm gonna house my
king on B8 and if you want the draw
you're welcome to it I think that was
the best move actually
best decision
because
F5 D5 look at that
wow he took a leaf out of your book
Ivanka just controlling that White
Knight with F6 Wesley so but suddenly
Magnus has the time to open things up
that black king
it might be in huge trouble he goes back
and how does Magnus continue now and
Wesley again looking up he's trying to
check what move number it is he's
struggling now under three minutes but
it's also the tension I think that he's
just
really dense
now how to continue five of course of
course
Buffalo now Magnus push forward at any
cost
but uh can the king not hide itself on
B8
Safety First when you have this type of
limited time but then already you can go
eat takes F6 takes on D5 F7 Knight D5
you protect I mean
[Laughter]
he does hide the black king on B8 we're
expecting Magnus now to either push or
take this Pawn I think take it I think
take it on F6 yep open up your Rook get
that past Pawn
let's make a decision Magnus Carson he's
maybe mulling over even capturing on C6
first though after he takes F6 maybe
Rook f8
just to hunt down this Pawn Yeah makes a
lot of sense will we see that variation
Wesley head in hand
goes for it oh fumbling the pieces that
Magnus a bit of nerves potentially no
his Pawn has landed on F7 where is
rookie 895
big big Initiative for white great
compensation for the material look at
this look at this past Pawn on F7 maybe
it's time to actually
um try and trade us Queens
our white will not agree to that trade
though surely yeah the queen slide okay
okay the queen oh 95 95 threats now
Knight folks all over the place
can he play it now yeah but what is this
can you give a check Wesley's banking on
the fact that he can give back some
material the White Knight can jump into
D7 with a family Fork there but it will
be captured immediately
should be winning you feel like for
Magnus he's got the safer King if he
wins back the material but still some
calculation to be done
and uh well Magnus plenty of time on the
clock he is just under four and a half
minutes
this is a very critical position
Wesley has two minutes to make 13 moves
what do you think about Queen Queen D7
[Laughter]
you're smiling on communities Queen to
D7 hoping the only thing I don't see the
threat
yeah I don't see the threat either yes
beautiful move though and it was forced
Wesley to think
can you
use the idea and play Queen to E8
yeah there would have been some tactics
there I'm not sure it was quite working
out but Magnus is going for direct
Checkmate he's lifted his Rook up
shifting it across the board
Queen A8 was a mate threat so black has
had to play C6 opening up space for his
King
he's got a run just like Harry and Harry
in his game the King has got to go on a
walk
but Magnus is hunting it down
surely this is winning for white judic
you're the attacker here is this
decisive
continue Rook B3
looks good
Wesley at this point looks up more in
Hope than expectation he's only got one
minute and 52 seconds and looks like the
black king is not going to survive that
long
and you do feel that there are some
ideas of Knight takes porn as well
Knight takes C6 threatened Knight takes
Rook on F7 threatened
or maybe now your idea yes
and I can capture on C6 there might be
better they might be even stronger maybe
just Queen B6 check
yeah take the material back and then
go for checkmate after
well if King C8 then yeah but also look
F3
F3 could be a killer in the next couple
of moves he plays it immediately drew
that nice spot there
full board awareness and that might work
is entering the seventh rank ah
no it's one The Rook is it's game over
it's game over
uh he can still oh no still not wow one
check and it's over
check
yeah
what a game what a gamble by Magnus
Carlson and there he takes it